[Musik]
es ist wichtig auf andere menschen
rücksicht zu nehmen
es ist wichtig versprechen zu halten
nico es ist sinnvoll einen putzplan zu
erstellen nico ich brauche das ist ein
geschoss
ich brauche ein putztuch oder ein
wischtuch putztuch hey ihr macht sauber
ja also ich mache ja eigentlich seit
wochen ständig sauber was ist eigentlich
aus sondern putzplan geworden ja ich
fand die idee super die arbeit
aufzuteilen und eine schwangerschaft ist
übrigens kein grund nicht mehr zu helfen
ich finde schon ich finde nicht nico und
ich wir also ich mache hier fast die
ganze arbeit alleine
ich darf mich aber nicht anstrengen dann
kaufen wir doch ein so potter jetzt
fangen nicht anbieter von diesem roboter
zu erzählen
nico alles okay keine ahnung seien
beantwortet seit gestern nicht mehr